so when I was 17 I had this scumbag boss
who was old enough to be my dad tell me
you're gonna save yourself for me when
you turn 18 now I have every right to
say that's really inappropriate you're
out of line but instead I did what I
always do when I'm uncomfortable I'm
gonna go oh my god you know sexual
harassment sucks but not being able to
confront it sucks more whenever some guy
says I want to fuck you
I want to say I need an adult but
instead it's always I'm gonna go I'm
gonna go you know it's funny because I
asked my mom about how to deal with
stuff like this and she said when you
want to be left alone you have to act
like a crazy person let me take home
I'll give it to you good what no way no
[Applause]
but I think part of the reason why I
just laugh and try to escape is because
I've always been really really really
paranoid and afraid of rape honestly
it's just it's just the way I have
always been and every time I walked in
my car at night I mentally plan out how
I'm gonna react if someone tries to jump
me I'm a rapist
but then I worry that it's gonna end up
like I'm gonna go and you know what it's
perfectly okay to tell someone that
their advances are unwanted and that
they're out of line and I personally
struggle with confrontation
so it's something I'm kind of still
working on
I'd enjoy allowing you you should go you
should go Finch progress that's all that
matters
I'll see you next Monday stay awesome
Gotham